طبعا هنا من جنين خضر عدنان القيادي في
الجهاد الاسلامي بالضفه الغربيه سيد خضر
عدنان هل لا زالت اشتباكات مستمره
رسول الله
انا اتفقنا اترحم على الشهداء مجزره
الاحتلال في جنين هذا عدوان
مستمر على عده اشهر وليس فقط ساعات همم
وهذا العدوان اليوم هو مجزره همم
وعلامات ميدانيه ولا حقائق الى مشفى جميل
واستخدام الجرافات
والتي فيها من يعني الشباب ومن اهالي في
مخيم جنين الاستهداف ولكل مخيم جنين وليس
للمقاومه في مخيم جنين
والاحتلال الذي يحاول همم يعني همم يبيض
صفحته السوداء بالقول ان هناك المقاومه
المقاومه تتكلم بكل شيء همم في الوقت
المناسب ولكن اعتقد بان همم ما حدث لنا ان
هذا الارهاب هو الارهاب بالحاضر الشعبيه
المقاومه بهذا الاحتلال والرفض وهذا
الاحتلال من الاهالي في مخيم جنين وعلى
المجتمع الدولي اليوم ام يرفع صوته عاليا
الذي اليوم هو ينزاح الى الحضن الصهيوني
واليوم نحن نقتل بصمت من حولنا هذا الصمت
دوليا
عن ان الهدف من وراء هذه العمليه هو
استهداف ثلاثه تصفهم اسرائيل بالمطلوبين
من حركه الجهاد الاسلامي تعليقكم على ذلك
الفلسطينيه
ان نفعل كل شيء للدفع الدفع عن شعبنا
والدفاع عن شعبنا ولكننا اليوم نكونها
للانسان مجزره في جنين
ورقص على دماءنا منها المتعجله الذي
البارحه قتل العديد من شبابنا في سلوان او
في شعفاطات او قرب
القدمين واليوم يقتل في هذا المجزره التي
تتكلم
الاحتلال لربما لم يعرف ان جميل كلما قتل
منها اكثر ازدادت مقاومه الاكثر الشباب
وفي
الضفه المحتله اعتقد في كل سرحات
الفلسطينيين اكثر غضبا عن هذه الاحتلال
ومقاومه ولكن دعوتنا اليوم ايضا يكرر
دعوتنا في الجهاد الاسلامي وفي مقاومه
الفلسطينيه للخروج للشوارع والساحات واا
يعني مراكز المدن في كل صحه وجدنا في غزه
في الضفه في القدس في الداخل في الشباب
دعوتنا للمنتخب العربيه والاسلاميه ان
يكون هذا يوم غضب على هذا الاحتلال المجرم
ما حدث في جميع يعني اقول لكل اهلنا
وناسنا ومسلمين واحرار العالم
معنا وهذا الاحتلال لا يرعوي الا بالمزيد
المقاومه والا بوحدتنا كاحرار على هذه
الارض
جميعا نريد ان نعرف هل اشتباكات مستمره
لانه علي سموه الصحفي من داخل جنين افاده
بتوجه همم اليات او مدرعات عسكريه همم الى
المخيم هل لا زالت الاشتباكات مستمره حتى
الساعه وان تتركز تحديدا
كلام الاستاذ علي
والصحفيين يؤثر على العدوان مستمر وان
دخول المركبات العسكريه المؤلله من منطقه
من غير نقطه عسكريه محيط محافظه جنين يقول
بان عدوان مستمر
الاحتلال
ايضا يعني فقد وتالق في هذا العدوان لان
الاحتلال كشفت ايضا يده الخبيثه بدخول
القوات الخاصه باستخدام ايضا مركبه بيع
الالبان وهذا ايضا كلمه للمؤسسات الدوليه
الطبيب الاحمر المؤسسات الدوليه العامله
في اراضيه الفلسطينيه المحتله استخدام هذه
المركبات همم من القوات الخاصه القاتله
المجرمه العبريه اليس خرقا لل- للمواثيق
الدوليه استخدام همم الشاحنات التي تنقل
الحديد والطعام الغذاء لتنقل لجنين اليس
مزيد من طرف هذا الاحتلال وهذه العرب بدا
صهيونيه استخدام احيانا حتى مرك الدوليه
ودخول ايام بين مركبات ايضا تعمل لشركات
فلسطينيه يعني ياخذونها او يصادرونها من
الشباب الفلسطيني ويحتجزونهم في اماكنهم
ادونهم عن الاتصالات ويدخلون بهذه
المركبات ويستخدمون ايضا شعارات تلك
الشركات الفلسطينيه العامله في الضفه
المحتله التي يعني نحن مطمئن لدخلها
لمناطقنا ليكون فيما بعد لقدر الله يعني
اشتباك حتى سيارات فلسطينيه من فلسطينيه
ويجب ان يكون هناك كلمه من الكل العربي
والاسباني منظمه المؤتمر الاسلامي اليوم
جامعه الدول العربيه